Jim car's bizarre and annoying Antics on
the set of man on the moon was so
strange Universal didn't want any behind
the-scenes footage released in Christmas
Netflix documentary Jim and Andy the
great beyond audiences saw this footage
for the first time while making Milo
foran's biopic about the excentric
comedian Andy kman Carrie got lost in
the role staying in character on said
for four months of filming in the
documentary Carrie says that when he got
the role kman Spirit tapped him on the
shoulder and took over what happened
afterwards was out of my control Carrie
certainly seems possessed by something
and it wasn't always fun for the cting
crew for example Carrie made everyone on
said call him Andy or Tony when Carrie
inhabited kofman's belligerent Alter Ego
Tony Clifton he was combative and rude
especially with Jerry Lawler going so
far as to spit in his face ultimately
Carrie won a Golden Globe for his
performance but for the casting crew
carer's method acting was unprofessional
and disruptive to the production